welcome back to las vegas now galleon
welker and beckstrom is home to the best
attorneys
in las vegas and they play a key role as
advocates for veterans and joining us
right now is travis
monica renee and michael they're here
today to tell us more welcome you guys
how are you
good great thank you i love this set up
as i want to sit down and have some
dinner together this is fantastic so
my first question is for you why is it
so hard for some vets to get
their va benefits well it's really
complicated process
and there's no real good road map out
there
and it's harder when they've waited a
long time to file their claims
so those things all put together it's
very complicated
and then when they win what do they get
well of course they get money and they
get acknowledgement
for what's happened to them and what
they're trying to claim and
then they get um they know someone cares
that's how we build our relationships
and our friendships
and and that's the key thing too to show
them that we do care and you guys care
and then
another question is why does it take so
long to get claims approved
i heard this could take a long time why
is that the case
well the va is huge and there's millions
and millions of veterans that are whose
claims are already in the pipeline
and so when somebody comes to the door
they don't understand that there's
veterans that have been waiting longer
than them
is there is there a way that you can
speed it up i'm taking you guys have a
way to speed things up and if so how is
it or how does it work
there is a way to speed it up and the
way to speed it up is to slow down
when you first put your paperwork in and
make sure that it's all done correctly
to start with
because any mistakes or any appeals can
take up to a year
or two to correct so
really you want to make sure that the
claim is correct when you put it in the
first time and that will speed it up
i love how that answer that you speed
things up by slowing it down and doing
things right when it comes to filing
paperwork so how does an attorney help
with the claims process
um well we we've been playing
uh this game with the va for a long time
so i have been since
07. so we have an uh institutional
knowledge we understand how the va works
and our goal is not to treat the va as
the enemy but to give them
what they need in order to grant the
claim so that's what we bring to the
table we know how to deliver
the information that the va needs in
order to grant the claim
well here's a question i'm not sure you
can answer it or not but how much does
an attorney cost
for their health well that's one of the
great things at least
as far as i'm concerned about working
with veterans on these claims is that it
doesn't cost the veteran anything out of
pocket
to have legal representation at the
beginning of the of the claim if we
believe that we can help the veteran
we sign them up we do a fee agreement
and we get paid directly by the va
out of the back pay that we win for the
veteran so
if we can prove that the va should have
been compensating them
and we get money for them then we take a
portion of that and they get the rest of
it and then from that point
that point forward any uh disability
benefits they get from that point on are
theirs
guys we really appreciate you doing
great things to help our veterans and we
truly appreciate your time today thank
you so much for joining us
thank you thank you you can give gallian
welker and beckstrom a call at
702-892-3500 or find them online
at st george law office dot com